Okay, welcome back, welcome to video
number 12. We've so far looked at
businesses within the world's largest
economy, the US, and within businesses
we've looked at the Manufacturing Report
on Business, the ISM, and we've also
looked at the Non-Manufacturing Report on
Business, the Non-Manufacturing Index, or
the Service Sector.
So we've looked at businesses, now we have
to look at the other thing within the
economy that makes up the vast majority of
economic spending, which is the US
consumer. Now the US consumer makes up two
thirds, two thirds of all spending in the
US economy. This is why it's so important,
because if we're going to attempt to
predict US GDP and
global GDP, well, if consumer spending is
66% of the world's largest economy, then
it's extremely significant. Now what do we
mean by consumer sentiment? Well, consumer
sentiment is how consumers feel about
their prospects, and whether they're going
to be spending more or less in the future.
If consumers are going to be spending less
in the future, then you can bet your
bottom dollar that the economy is probably
not going to grow. In fact, it may
contract. And also, if consumers are going
to plan to spend more, you can bet your
bottom dollar that the economy is not
going to shrink. The economy is not going
to contract. In fact, it's probably going
to do the opposite. It's going to expand.
Now if you use the University of Michigan
consumer sentiment index in conjunction
with the PMIs that we've looked at on the
business side, you're going to get a very
good coverage and a very good idea of
what's going to happen to the world's
largest economy.
Now I want you to think all the time when
you're looking at consumer sentiment
indicators across the world, because the
US isn't the only place in the world that
has consumer sentiment indicators. Other
countries have them as well. We have them
in Europe and Asia.
I want you to think when you look at
consumer sentiment indicators globally
what you're actually thinking yourself as
a consumer and what your friends are
thinking and what your work colleagues are
thinking.
And when you go out into the public
domain, you should always, as a trader, be
trying to sample what sentiment is like
within the consumer sector and also within
businesses.
Because if you marry up these two things,
so you marry up the official statistics of
the leading indicators and also your own
experiences, you're going to have an
extremely good idea of what the future
prospects of the economy are.
Now you're also going to get, when you
marry them all up, a good idea of what
government policy is going to be in the
future.
If consumers aren't spending and
businesses are planning to cut back, then
all that's going to happen is the economy
is going to shrink.
And what are we going to see down the
line? Well, we're going to see down the
line government policy, which is easing,
as in lower interest rates, in an attempt
to bolster the economy.
And we're going to get, we're going to get
the opposite when the situation is vice
versa.
So let's have a look at the University of
Michigan consumer sentiment index.
It's the most important consumer sentiment
index in the world.
There's others, obviously, in Europe and
in Asia, which are important, but this is
by far the most important.
And the ones in other countries are very,
very similar and we treat them in very
similar ways, but we should be
concentrating on the US.
66% of spending in the US economy is very
significant.
Okay, let's go to the presentation and
I'll see you at the end of the video with
a summary of the University of Michigan
consumer sentiment index.
Next one, University of Michigan consumer
sentiment index.
Why is consumer confidence or consumer
sentiment important?
Yeah, so if all consumers, there's only
two things in the economy, businesses and
consumers.
What we've looked at so far are
businesses.
So we've looked at manufacturing companies
and non-manufacturing companies.
That makes up 100% of businesses.
What's on the other side?
Consumers.
Consumers make up in the United States two
thirds of all aggregate demand in the
economy.
So why is that important?
Well, if their confidence is low and they
think the world's going to end 12 months
from now, what do consumers do?
They tighten their belts.
And if they're full of confidence and they
think the world's going to grow, their
salaries are going to be higher next year.
What do they do now?
They spend.
So consumer sentiment is important.
What you're going to get from the
University of Michigan consumer research
center each month is a telephone, the
results of a telephone survey.
And believe it or not, this indicator has
80, 85% correlation to the business cycle
with a 12 month time lag.
And the survey is only 500 consumers in
the United States.
It's amazing.
And they get asked a series of questions
about their personal finances and their
opinions on future business conditions.
So essentially they're testing current
conditions and expected conditions.
And within the UMCSI is an expectations
index and a current conditions index with
an equal weighting.
That's what it looks like versus GDP
growth since 1978.
Now the consumers, the University of
Michigan consumer sentiment index is
different to the ISM and manufacturing and
non-manufacturing index.
Because there's no kind of predetermined
level which is growth expected or
contraction expected like in the PMIs
where you have the 50 level where above 50
it's growing, below 50 it's contracting or
predicted to.
The consumer sentiment survey, what you
need to do is draw a trend line right
through the middle.
So a simple trend line.
Simple average.
Moving average.
Yeah.
And that in the consumer surveys equates
since 1978 to 85 here.
85 in the consumer sentiment survey.
And we've got GDP growth on the left.
So what does that equate to?
The long term trend equates to 3% GDP
growth in the United States.
And that 3% is the long term average
growth rate of the US economy.
So what's the US predicted to grow out
this year?
One and a half, 2%.
Sounds fair.
What was it predicted to be last year?
And the year before?
What's the US economy been growing at
since they came out of the recession?
In the middle of 2009.
One to 2%.
That is totally reflected in the fact that
this has been below long term trend since
here, which is 2007-8.
So you can see pictorially that it's been
right.
Now what you can do, I kind of look at the
consumer sentiment index as a zonal
indicator.
So if you get readings between 60 and 70,
things are really bad because we're
predicted to get contraction.
If you get readings below 70 and 80,
things are neither here nor there.
The US is growing or predicted to grow,
but below long term trend.
If you get readings above 80, 85, that's
pretty bullish for the economy because
it's predicted to grow at the long term
growth rate.
And right now, if that was the case, we'd
all be having a big disco party.
The US would kill for 3% right now.
So look at it in terms of a zonal play, 60
to 70, 70 to 80, anything above 80, US is
predicted to grow at long term trend.
Yeah?
That's the expectations index.
That's the more important index for you as
a trader because the expectations index is
aligned with your objective of predicting
the future.
So what are consumers expecting they will
be doing with their own spending a year
from now?
If they're really, really bearish, it
means the economy is going to have
problems in a year's time.
If they're really bullish, disco party.
And what you'll find is the current
conditions trend over time will follow the
expectations trend.
There they are all on one chart.
So go into these things online and learn
about them in depth.
It's worth doing.
You can have very, very in-depth and
intelligent conversations with
professional traders when you go for
interviews at investment banks and hedge
funds if you're going through all of the
leading indicators and surmising a world
view.
And saying, I think we should just be
long.
Because you can go into it so in-depth and
so scientifically that you forget what's
important.
What's important is just to make money.
And if you're long at the right time,
you'll make money.
If you're short at the right time, you'll
make money.
If you're between 67% and 93% every year
for the rest of your life, so you predict
three quarters out of four per year and
you're correct, you'll kill it.
You'll make money for the rest of your
life.
So why is consumer sentiment important?
Obvious, predicting GDP.
Obvious, predicting stock market returns.
And because economies are made up of only
businesses and consumers,
a head check against what's happening in
the ISM reports.
So if you look at all three every month,
you're going to be building up a very,
very good picture of what's going on in
the United States or what's going to
happen in the United States.
And therefore, in all probability, the
rest of the world.
Again, you'll get the spreadsheets.
Don't worry.
It's all going to be okay.
Okay, welcome back.
So what did we learn there from the
University of Michigan Consumer Sentiments
Index?
Well, we've learned that it's a very, very
important measure.
And we can use this in tandem with the ISM
Manufacturing Report on Business and the
Non-Manufacturing Index.
So when we look at the University of
Michigan Consumer Sentiments Indicator,
what we've learned here is really, it's
very highly correlated again with GDP in
the United States.
Because this high correlation when using
it in conjunction with the ISM
Manufacturing Report on Business and the
Non-Manufacturing Report on Business.
When you're using this in conjunction with
them, you're going to get an extremely
good idea of the health and the future
prospects of the U.S. economy, U.S. GDP
and therefore global GDP.
And then it can decide for you or even
confirm or deny whether to take a long,
short or market neutral position in your
portfolio within the stock market,
currencies, commodities and rights.
Now, one of the things that we learned
when we were in the presentation just
there was that there is no level really in
the Consumer Sentiment Index similar to
the 50 level of the ISM Manufacturing
Report on Business
and the Non-Manufacturing Index where
we've got contraction and expansion
defined and indicated as in below 50
contraction above 50 expansion.
We don't have that with the Consumer
Sentiment Index but when you look at the
data going back to 1978, what we do find
is correlated levels with certain levels
of GDP.
And the long term average level of the
University of Michigan Consumer Sentiment
Index is 85 and this coincides with the
long term GDP growth rate of the United
States of 3%.
So, if we have levels below in the UMCSI
below 85, this is going to be correlated
with lower levels of GDP growth in 3% and
above 85, higher levels of GDP growth
above 3%.
Now, when you're looking at levels which
are contraction levels, you're probably
looking at levels below 65, 70, around
that level.
That's where we look for the University of
Michigan Consumer Sentiment Indicator to
give us a prediction that in a year's time
the US economy may actually shrink,
contract and may even go into recession as
in two negative quarters of real GDP
growth.
So, these levels are fairly important
because consumers 12 months in advance are
giving us very, very good ideas as to the
levels of GDP growth, not just the
direction.
So, when you marry these up with the
levels of above and below 50 in the
manufacturing and non-manufacturing PMIs,
you not only get direction but you may get
indicated levels of GDP growth.
So, that's what's important about the
University of Michigan Consumer Sentiment
Indicator.
Marry them up with the business PMIs as in
business sentiment and make sure you give
your best shot to predicting not only the
direction of US GDP growth but also the
levels of what we should be expecting.
Okay, the next indicator that we're
actually going to look at is the building
permits indicator which is very, very
important for the US housing sector.
So, let's move on to video 13. I think
you'll find this one quite fun. It's one
of my personal favourites.
favourites.